Ecuador
[Music]
[Music] [
Music]
bien cachorro carajo
[Music]
alucta tu Windows
hunters in tierra del fuego [Music] [Music
]
Everybody
[Music]
Ecuador in Peru
Good morning go
ahead
and pay attention we're going  let's make the U-turn
yes accent U-turn
very attentive
[Music]
U-turn and now yes [
Music] [
Applause]
Hello how are you [
Music]
[Applause] we are
going to move all the chains
we are going to move the whole race
this
and we are going
very well very well
[Applause]
Hello, how are you, how are you, how are you,
how old is he,
89,
89, almost two more months and walking, he
seems to have some illness or
is he healthy,
yes, eyesight, especially
eyesight, the flu, no longer  He sees well, yes
Little by little but he sees me
Yes, how I am
is pinkish white
with everything
Ah Well, still What is your name? My
name is Rosalina Pineda Fernández my
name [
Music]
the pinkish one
[Laughter]
89 years of life
still healthy and to  the age that
I am What is the secret of a long
life
there I would not want to have a long life a lot
really really is already tired of
life and
in old age one can no longer
do what used to be made to work
but now  you want to die
and Lora is coming what to do
you have to determine
[Music]
to return to America
Why is it that the people of Vilcabamba
come to have a long life here
because of their health at the same time in the first
place the  health health but how do you
take care of your health here here well
anyway taking the right food
that the person has to eat not
any food fruit fruit
you eat enough
life Even if you are old you like
the skin better
[Laughter]
[Music]
Don  second
Don second Don
second
hello Don
how are you
how are you have a strong hand a
strong handshake
[Laughter]
How old are you How old are you
has to be more than more than 100 how much one
hundred and three years in the four now in
June on day
and  Still working
How old is your wife
65 65
[Music]
Don second in me
smoking and drinking [
Music]
me Don second
[Music]
but if you were born in 1913 you must be 104 not
43 years old and at
No  He's already turned 104
Yes
[Laughs]
because it's from 1913 thanks
[Music]
Don Segundo
Scape [
Music]
dancing with loves
[Music]
they go blind for not having fallen off
because they can't see because of the horns I'm going to
compadre
[Music  ]
Good morning
of a good strength you healthy
in Ecuador from Quechua India
quater people State for long time to the
sus Because of
plans like the botterfulcabamba
[Music]
Plants which is First Medical
three times and you do a  little thing
that you don't lack any fruit that God
blesses you
like this We give to the bad mom bad bad bad
bad means
that we are asking mother earth to
protect him from all bad
energy to father sun to mother moon to
Lord of heaven So that
means crappy crappy So the child will
be healthy and calm and will not grow up very well
and will not be a crybaby
sometimes children cry for everything
so when the child is healed he doesn't
cry a lot he cries sometimes
Mom and dad won't rest
[Music] she
flies
very strong
[Music]
she has, that is, she says her
belly hurts and it won't take five days, so I
want her to get better. I want to see if she has, I
'm going to clean her  guinea pig to
see if it has heat or cold
and then we are
[Music] [
Music]
to really live the guinea pig dies and then
it is peeled.
the guinea pig
dies by itself why is it because he has a
disease if he doesn't have a
guinea pig disease he doesn't die then that's why he
understood me because now he's
sick he wasn't jumping
[Music]
And if we let him live  the guinea pig is what
you want, I'll leave it to you Yes, of course,
and it carries the bad all the disease, all
the bad energy, the guinea pig carries what the
lady is sick the guinea pig carries, if
you want, I'll
always leave her, a cross is made for her,
then we see  and he walks he
left so nice
[Music]
thank you
Well This is the corridor where we are going to
enter the life of
María soltadora
the founder that is a mother firewood like
you I am from the north of Spain
and I came in 54
realize the  years that I have been here I
was a girl when I came when I was young Not
so much no but how old do you give me
now I am
about 70
I am 89
[Laughter] it
has been taken care of here
How do you think
Colombia Spain chile Mexico
the man announced to María
In The Final stage of Life
[Music]
de hasta la in Spanish Nicaragua
[Music] [Music
] [
Music]
Very good night
how are you how are you what's new
no permission very good night
how are you how are you
bye madrecita
are you with the nun
blessing
what do you have  Mrs. Doña Lilia
has terminal cancer in the colon
And how much time they gave her
to die Well, only God knows But it
is already in its terminal stage and you will be
days away If she wanted to
finish sooner Oh no no because that
would already be euthanasia
Not here what  what we give is complete
comprehensive care of the whole
being, both of the soul and of the body.
So you can see the spiritual part, that's
why in this hospice, which is Catholic, they say
it's excellent for
Catholics, euthanasia is out of the
question. Yes, not that.  It is
obviously forbidden, it goes without saying, that
is, in our religion
we love life from the very
beginning Until the Lord takes us
because God wants it that way,
to bring Christ to the sick and at the same time
the sick is for us a Christ
who needs our  care and
attention and affection
[Music]
cemetery cemetery doesn't even come back to my
daughter
sedentary cemetery
[Music]
Open your gates soon
Mr.
Gravedigger
Open soon I want to
[Music]
pray to my life
put those white flowers Azucena
and the most beautiful choir that will address
and put
more beautiful [Music] that will adorn loose Thank you
very much thank you very much thank you
Are you fine Yeah
having a hard hard hard hit yes it's
been 11 years and the truth
is like a memory in our
hearts but it will last forever
Who died my sister
my baby and the truth I mean if I
remember her we have them is alive in
other hearts but with God of Marcial
Thank you very much
[Music]
is that you are working
if you should be at
your mother-in-law's wake  first it's work
then fun when
[Music]
Ecuador died
and human in sketch All the jokes about
motor
my mother-in-law left now I did
n't see a broom coming out there Oops
it's gone it
's nothing
[Music]
[Music  ]
[Music] there used to be
a couple who
secretly loved each other but their mom didn't let them
be together but wanted to have
separated them one night I think their mom
grabbed them just when they were together
so
there they sort of made a  How do you
say witchcraft or magic and how
they transformed them to be
together because they
deserved to be together and that they
transformed the woman transformed the man into
a milkman the husband
transformed into the lagoon I put him says they
have put him  in the bush to
keep an eye on him because she is very jealous and they still
love each other. Yes, they say that their
parents still did not let their partners be
like this United
[Music] [
Music]
[Applause]
the amount
[Laughter]
[  Laughs]
with love
[Laughs] he
doesn't like it
[Music] [
Laughs]
a minute from the plants I have
enough syringes at the same time
and it hurts Until it's over and it takes
like an hour
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
definition  of Love
en camino Right now coming from
that we are starting there
[Laughter] I
can't say anything bad you
call her mommy yes
we say solomita
[Music]
Hello
good afternoon
already
taken in
to hard but it couple
I
didn'ts the problems of this  single
[Music]
whose land you're
working on
this belongs to us it's an
inheritance
from my mother-in-law
she inherited it to you or your wife to
my wife since I don't have a job my
mother-in-law didn't like her  she thought I was going
to leave her with the children
she looked like a bum without mold And that she
told you not to get married because I won't be
able to support If you had a study a
profession
she wouldn't be saying those
words to me I mean where I mean where we live
in  this in this in this land
everything the majority of men work
more than women but
suddenly my husband
is not it is not like that I mean I am like
I mean as a man I work
both in the money and in the
land then  Seeing these things my
mom didn't like it
and it didn't bother you yes it bothers me that is I take
my husband out but not with my mom
no you don't regret not having listened
to your mom
yes sometimes yes sometimes
yes
sometimes when we  We argued and
what bothers me is that I mean,
put a little effort
into work
that I would like but with everything that
was happening I still have love for
him
[Music]
[  Music]
What is a landfill man chagra
man chagra means man Tiller
of the land
the charrería is to till the land
to build
your Treasury have your cattle have your
enclosures have your embryos and
enjoy these festivals that give us
the  opportunity the city
[Music]
the chakras are very
How to say it I mean they are very ostentatious I
can control the horse I can
do this I mean they are more rude
and they think that because of what they are or what
they have they can have anyone
woman there at her feet you could say they are
much more macho
[Music] [
Music]
How about your bad mother-in-law
because
I was married seven years ago
Thank you from my mother and my father I was
with her She did a lot of damage to my mother-in-
law my mother-in-law Why  What did she do? She didn't
like that I am her husband.
Her daughter did many things to me and here is the
mother-in-law here. Here she is, where she is, you already
greeted her. Why do I have to say
hello?
It's a damn And where is the mother-in-law
over there
Just
lines already
as a band here where the boss is,
rojalaquito sweater
And what color shirt has
a plumes and roses stripe
?
and a good husband was forbidden to talk
about her
but he never liked that he
ate himself
and he continues to be together with the woman for two
months
the mother-in-law yes the mother-in-law and now the mother-in-law
son of a [ __ ]
managed to get him to marry another It really
was worse  that my son of a [ __ ] is that
and now I'm sorry The old son of a
[ __ ] the mother-in-law are damned poisonous snakes
[Music]
[Applause] [
Music]
headache Oh
there's aspirin for headaches and it's over
[Music]
[Applause]
when you have another voice and from the house
we ate
and in the house with limosa
the roario Make Me Love in America event
more
but delivers and Presley formed in the
have deeper mini
[Music]
where did that newspaper come out my
murdered daughter came out  As a student,
a teacher murdered her student.
The beautiful woman was
shot in the neck by the subject.
Apparently it was personal trouble. He
is her son-in-law, is it true,
or did she not call him yesterday?
He doesn't know how much damage he did
and why he says.  He's still looking for it because
he's still looking for it he flew away
no no the police didn't catch him
he's still on the run they already gave him
the hearing they already gave him 25 years
25 years 25 years
but he's not in jail he's not in jail
I'm not telling him that the more  before I miss
her more I don't know if it's because I'm
getting older But the truth is
that I miss that girl a lot
No there isn't a day in my life that I
don't remember her I stand at the
window I said soon what  I must enter
because I do
not want it even to my worst enemy that I
do not have
nor him because I am leaving everyone my
God
my heart does not have to hate anyone
I only ask for
justice
if there is no human justice that is
God's I believe a lot in  God a lot
And why the Amazon out of jealousy Jealousy jealousy
because he already told him that he didn't live
with him anymore So he was a very
proud man he was used to the fact that the
woman begged him and everything So
why had he never had one
like my daughter
that goddess  lean forward pretty
[Music]
voice
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
I get up with life in the spirit
[Music] [Music
] [
Music]
you are a quiet mother-in-law
[Music]
would find the  place to stop the
gentleman
from Colombia import
a minute commines
[Music] The
water is good
[Music]
who says that the river is a living being, no, and
the river is not only the water we want to
pass through, but the people who live from it,
those who  We live near the river and all of that
makes it of great importance
for everyone at a commercial cultural level in
the way of life of the people and for
all that. And I think there is a need to say
bad things about the name
in the breeze
[Music]
[Music  ]
[Music] he takes it lets it
go Hello vote
[Music]
Denisse that have of colombias fishing
Hill from the Magdalena
When I said I really like the name
Magdalena
and Latinos
from that bridge who have been
doing it for a long time and I think not anymore  It ends
in the next year. Aha, this bridge is progress.
Great progress,
that one goes to Bogotá
and those who go to other
parts pass through there. You like that progress on
this bridge. Yes, for the country, how much
will one earn there anyway?  ways it is
progress for Honda and it
works for us because the truth is I would like to see a
car pass by yes
How has the fishing been the fishing has
been regular right now but it has always
been bad around three years ago
here
It is due to the fact that the slough  They are covered and
no fish come out So the fish don't
go up here Right now we are waiting for
the rise to hope that
hope will always improve they don't get
lost yes We always go forward
we go forward
[Music] [
Music]
[Music]
Don Pablo in escapton
that they came looking at the river and taking
measurements with a map that they brought
from the banks And how the water hit it hard
and And
where the smaller rivers
and Magdalena flowed and they told him what they came
to do or did not
speak Chinese Yes sir no  I didn't understand him at all
but they were kind
a Chinese company that was already the one that
bought this Magdalena river bought the
Magdalena river a Chinese company how it
bought it but negotiated with the
Colombian state the Colombian government
until save Story
and it doesn't seem good for
progress to come  to Colombia
Well, the problem is very good, yes, because they will
see the navigation of the ships, Yes,
but they are going to get on, it's them, not
us. Of course, he
says how slavery has happened before with the
Spanish.
Yes machinery and everything and they are going to bring the
boats and all that but Colombia had
the capacity to dredge the river if
Colombia has the means to dredge the
river Yes of course Colombia has money
to buy machines Why have they not done it they
don't  because that is
their strategy to take the money from the
big politicians and distribute it from
pocket to pocket, yes, of course, it
is a business of the Colombian government,
which is corrupt,
it is understood,
Don Pablo
history seen to repeat self
I wrong play the Spanish pressure Hot
name is reform
Don Pablo set the Rivera
[Music]
reputation
pecadora pecadora
ostia
[Music]
hostias [
Music]
Magdalena [Music
]
María María [Music
] [Music
]
buenas buenas mujer
[Music]
[Applause]
cilla Márquez
[Music] [
Music]
Magdalena
[Music]
now he became
what I
lived with him for four years, he lived with him
Yes, because we in Look at that curve
all over the Lomita curve There is a molla that
calls him la mola Perico
is not there  a ranch that we had
My father had there
and I was sent to bring water because of the
lie we have to draw the
water and I went and found him sitting
like that he was on a rock
like that he was sitting
and I arrived and said good morning
he didn't  He answered me
and I greeted him and he didn't answer I put my
hand here on his back he looked at me
And since he looked at me like that's a
Moya a big blowout that
Rock came from there and turu spilled the water it's
hard for him to see with his hair Yes but  You
have really seen it or you tell me
because you are playing your role.
he is a god he is a name yes they say he was
evil in real life he was supposedly a shaman
and the girls that the moham takes away
are virgins too yes he has to be
between 12 and 14 years old
and what does he do to those girls  He
takes her to the I put her
where he lives
only makes him suck her breasts
just
nothing more no more it's
not against the law that's
not
but they're minors
oh no but not that's already in the in the in the
story of the
original muan and not mine anymore Oh you do
n't
[Music]
[Music] [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
and over the
muan master and lord of the waters owner of
the fish the moam lives throughout  of the
Magdalena River is the myth that announces and
has as its mandate respect for
nature and good fishing practices,
represents exuberance, indomitability, the
joyous and reproductive force of life,
comes out enraged in the form of an avalanche,
floods, and steals women as punishment
for  The Fishermen who have infringed the
rules of the River
yes
asmania
[Music]
Legend or simple [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]
here lasted three days two nights
until Saturday the 16th at 10 in the morning
when the girl died you  I knew her
Yes, I had the opportunity to live next
to them the girl was a tall, thin, dark-haired girl
she was little bloody she doesn't
pray that I can walk and these
people help me
Mommy loves you very much my daddy brother
[Music]
to 16th street
and it's  to the race 18
[Music]
house of housing gunsmith It was a city
where there was no lack of work, no
and of the constructions pure reinforced concrete
[Music]
elegant
I believe in God
God said help yourself that I will help you
if it exists  a God because he did not foresee that I
don't know I don't know I don't
know that I
ask myself I
come to work and I'm out there alone and
I start to analyze the land and
see what it was like to remember how he was a gunsmith and
sometimes I say what you told me  He is
saying if a God existed. Why did he let
this city end? That's true, I
ask myself. I haven't found the
answer No, nor will you ever find it.
It's been 32 years that have passed, but you don't
forget this, you never forget this in
life when  one dies not to
forget one all these all this
problem that happened here
[Music]
the week of the gunsmith tragedy
change Colombia
seven days of Justice in Bogotá Boston
carry [
Music]
weakness Center
[Music]
they came from Africa and were
reproduced here  many many of them and
enter legal they entered with
legal permits the community
began to interact with them to
interact to see them to know them But
the important thing is that we have always
known that they are dangerous that they are
aggressive So there
has been like that awareness
here  Colombians that we should
respect them and that we should not invade their
territory because
most of them were really born here
in Colombia.
They have the habitat, it is here, they
learned to see motorcycles, vehicles,
lights, many people passing by,
so somehow they
also learned to accept us.
we have adapted they have
adapted to this country
[Music]
What Don Pablo Magdalena was like he was a
slightly obese person with very
black wavy hair and black eyes and a
handsome little cheek yes he was a
handsome guy here many people had the
opportunity to meet him because there were  a
corregimiento that he loved a lot because of the
reserve of the claro cornasur river So
he loved that river very much because it had
crystal clear waters he did sport fishing
it is a river that was a navigable ship
so he had his boats to navigate what
they wanted in this sector yes Pablo is that
Pablo is I think Pablo is divided into
two men Well, into a good one and a bad one
Yes, the bad one, well, from his story about
drug trafficking, the bombs and
having gotten involved in politics, yes, he
tortures them Exactly So, but Pablo
had another good side that caught up with him
to make known in the communities
[Music]
[Music] you
would like it too I keep here if I
work
clear
you consider yourself a Communist
clear like I don't think we are
very close relatives but if you are capable of
trembling with indignation every time we
an injustice is committed in the world we are
companions who are more important
[Music] [
Music]
Nicolás Maduro representatives [
Music] [
Music]
[Music]